皆さん
この動画のずう妖精日ついてください
毎晩いつもローソンと夜をともにしているこの僕が
ローソンの商品を紹介するってことは
これで本当に
本当にオススメってことですよ本当に本当にオススメですよホント
ローソンに住んでいるような人間がですね
ローソンの商品を紹介することはもう本当に本当にも hots
家影 see お試しかの帰れま10とかでん
ローソンのデザートの第一だったということで
まあ世間的にも本当においしい行っとられている省人化です
ボケラマいつも石井運営チェーン
一つ言っておくんですけどチーフが強いがテーマつは本当に食ったら
します
パパは
本当にこんな感じです
小さいんですけど
もう味が凝縮されてるんじゃなあこの量でいいですよ
チーズの臭いが強いです
でこれなんかうわあああっんじゃ
なんだろジャック低いみたいのは好き爪ちゃって
すごいなんかちょっと探訪的には水はけが良い
とてもいいとチェーンになってるんでしょうね
本当に美味しいですこれああ
ファッ方
甘い保存ず人がチーズ好きの人食ったらほんとにねー
もうねぇパニックになりますよあまりの一言に尽きる
サッカー
あジャケットぜひ
プロゾンのぎゅっとクリームチーズ130円で
ロゾに
売ってるんで
ぜひ食べてみてください
者だ
ん